yeah mommy um you know she's uh well
she's she's I mean she's the main force
behind even Who I am you know because
obviously you know is the mother that
really as a child are the mother that
directs the reason are the children and
from a young age although she went on
tour with with my father a lot
she left us with her aunt who was very
discipline and so she knew that we would
get a good upbringing when she was in
her own but she's ever a strong woman
and very very caring about other people
and so she does all these type of things
in Jamaica in Africa everywhere she go
should all these type of charity work
for the kids and yeah she's always she's
and she's enough with the scrounger
stuff you know she'd get if there's like
some tea a bazaar or some clue that
people don't want she him up and
send him to Africa she's very down to
earth because she's from she's from that
place you know so she really work hard
for help people you know
I'm gonna tell mommy I just love it I
love my mother that's the most that's
the greatest thing I can say